good morning guys I'm just thinking I'm
trying to remember one state can we do
that again sorry let's see I wish it
because I'm melding it as you're seen
yeah like I'm cheering you Jared morning
believe nation today's message is
solitude matters over to you Susan Cain
Steve Wozniak invented the first Apple
Computer sitting alone in his cubicle
and hewlett-packard where he was working
at the time and he says that he never
would have become such an expert in the
first place had he not been too
introverted to leave the house when he
was growing up now of course this does
not mean that we should all stop
collaborating and case in point is Steve
Wozniak famously coming together with
Steve Jobs to start Apple Computer but
it does mean that solitude matters and
that for some people it is the air that
they breathe and in fact we have known
for centuries about the transcendent
power of solitude it's only recently
that we've strangely begun to forget it
if you look at most of the world's major
religions you will find seekers Moses
Jesus Buddha Muhammad seekers who are
going off by themselves alone to the
wilderness where they then have profound
epiphanies and revelations that they
then bring back to the rest of the
community
so no wilderness no revelations what do
you think my background in psychology
are I mean at least I studied psychology
and university I'm a strong believer and
self-actualization being the best that
you can be and I know for our
entrepreneurs you know as you start to
go to different people for opinions
start to get information start to grow
your business so much that sometimes
there is too much white noise and you
got to remove yourself and be able to
digest it I think of it as almost like a
computer you know when you start to
Unwin with Windows computers you defrag
a computer right to clean up the memory
and organize things so this so even
simple things like sleeping getting
enough sleep it helps you just center
yourself so
solitude self-actualization growth is
just as important as being out in the
world and talking to people and working
with people and collaborating is to find
a good balance of that yeah I think
everybody has to find their own cadence
I think it really depends on how
introverted extroverted you are I'm much
more introverted I need solitude every
day if I don't get it I start to freak
out if I'm in a really stressful
situation I go inwards right like don't
talk to me don't bother me like give me
a room by myself and I'll figure out an
answer to whatever problem we're facing
some people who are more extroverted
they go crazy when there's too much time
by themselves phrase like alright gotta
get out and I gotta go to a coffee shop
or something just to be around other
people I think to the extreme if you're
always around other people then you need
to everybody needs some amount of
solitude I think just you have to figure
out where you fit on the spectrum I
would probably a lot more than Alex
would just based on our personalities so
just find your cadence this is something
that I try to make I try to be really
self aware of where in my life things
get out of balance and you'll find that
as you grow and build and you build a
family you build a business things get
added to your schedule you will at some
point find some things are out of
balance like I'm not spending enough
time with my wife or I'm not spending
enough time by myself and and I do a
regular audit to see where is my life
out of balance and how can I inject more
stability for me so I can run
effectively in according to my cadence
so I think it's important for everybody
just you got to gotta go with the flow
and see which one like how much shelter
you need for yourself you know what I'm
actually gonna go a little bit on a
different side of it there was a
motivational speaker with an a previous
job who came in when I was working and
he said you know when they talk about
work/life violence he doesn't believe in
work-life balance and he said it's about
harmony actually because the whole word
of balance implies that there are these
scales and you put enough here you put
enough here and your personal life and
your work life somehow balance out and
it's almost like you set yourself up to
fail actually so harmony if you think of
your life as sort of a symphony right
you have certain you know you
the oboe you have the violin they play
at their own levels and what you want to
find and what's perfect that you've ever
gone to listen to a symphony is when all
the instruments play in harmony whether
there are thirty violins and two drums
or 20 drums and thirty violins right
yeah that's right
there that's what matters and I think
this you know it's all about
visualization of in any kind of industry
that you are in so if you visualize how
do I find harmony with my friends with
my lover with everything in your life
that will have more value than saying
that I need to balance these scales
because then you tend to want to stress
out and you know that bogs you doubt oh
I'm not spending enough time with my
family I'm not spending enough time this
instead of you said you'd be coming from
well how do I provide a little bit more
time for my family to make sure that
everything sounds nice
I think to add to that I would say the
song always changes yeah right so like
you may get it right for this one song
but then something new gets like you
have a new job now or now you have a kid
right to another song changes so you
have to find harmony constantly right
look it's a it's a you're never you know
you might be totally in balance now but
then you got to continue to adjust as
the song changes in your life yeah so
the question of the day today is how do
you find harmony in your life thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
- recipe Vigo